it's the letter they were dreading
instructions from the home office to
Afghan evacuees in hotels they have to
find somewhere else to live or face
homelessness
shirara sawari is 19. she was a
journalist in Kabul she says she feels
abandoned it's so hard for me because
I'm alone here I can't find the house
and here I don't have job was this what
you're expecting when you got on the
plane to come to the UK they don't have
any good plan for us for Afghan refugee
the letter applies to those who were
airlifted out of Kabul when the Taliban
retook control in August 2021 all who
have come through relocation schemes the
government has become frustrated by some
evacuees turning down offers of
accommodation where an offer of
accommodation can be made and is turned
down another will now not be forthcoming
but for the first time it's become clear
the majority of the 8 000 evacuees still
in hotels won't now be found somewhere
to move to the letter says it's likely
that most people will not receive an
allocation through the new process and
we encourage you to find your own
accommodation wherever possible the
letter urges people to search property
websites like Rightmove and zoopla
the Afghan evacuees we spoke to in
Hertfordshire say they've put down
routes in the community unlike Asylum
Seekers they can work but so long after
arriving they don't want to move yet
can't afford local rents
Waheed Works in a shop and has three
children settled in school I've seen
more than 25 properties I didn't get
none of this property so if I didn't get
none of this property it looks like it's
almost impossible for me
the government says moving to settled
accommodation will help people to fully
integrate Muhammad has been a taxi
driver in Britain since 2015 and lived
between the UK and Afghanistan when he
was caught up in the evacuation I'm
looking every day by day but it's very
hard some people will say you've had a
British passport since 2007 you have a
bank account
why should the British taxpayer be
paying for you to be in a hotel that is
good question where shall I go what
shall I do who gonna support my income
is not enough
the home office says it will provide
dedicated staff to offer guidance to
evacuees on how to rent but it's one
million pound a day hotel bill for them
has to end Lisa Holland Sky News